goody with the shoes
once you obviously honoring kobe bryant
the other nipsy hustle
andrew heating is on the mound for his
second start
of the young season he threw the ball
very well
against the oakland athletics in his
first time around 25 years of age this
was lifted out to ryden it's playable
for brian goodwin
one down he tried to run that fastball
up in the zone as well
or just paint the corner yeah that was a
delayed call
oh he taught him off up and away then in
tight two strikeouts for andra heaney
want to start as we head to the bottom
of the first inning
24 year old right hander justin done
getting ready for his 2020
debut usually that in this early going
has been the second
maybe third time around through the
order sieger nice play for sure now
goes across in time to get fletcher went
down foul ball
breaking ball sky center
make that right center field tim lopes
put up some good numbers the last two
years swinging the bat
on queue and load a diving catch
outstanding jump and otani's retired on
one pitch pitching for the kansas city
monarchs
against josh gibson here's a swing and a
ground ball right side out there in
shallow right
field is d gordon he's got it throws to
white at first and it's in time to get
la stella
nice play by gordon way out there in
shallow right field
205 hits and he locked him over that
fastball
two down here comes the 3-2 on odom
and that one is a pitch he takes a
sinker got him looking
and that is how the inning will end he
couldn't look any better here through
three innings he has set down eight of
nine
swag in a miss he got him first
strikeout swinging second toe
mariner's in business one outrunners at
the corners here in the fourth
and hard that's a base hit that'll pick
up a run mariners have a one-nothing
lead rbi for kyle seeger
his fourth of this young season the
angels opportunity right here with
shohei ohtani
shohei rips one out toward right field
lopes moving back on this one he pulls
up that one
is gone big fly ohtani shot
his first of the year the angels have
themselves a 3-1 lead
well he went back to that pitch again
and this time
shohei pretty good indication how strong
he
is seventh home run for the halos this
season first of the year for
ohtani now four rbis
break a ball breaking ball
and then shohei going yard
so goodwin will be the next batter
here's the 3-1
and it's a fly ball hit the center field
that ball is carrying out in center out
on the warning track and that one is
gone
goody blasted out the dead center that
ball just kept carrying
lewis the center fielder kept going back
and it gets
over the wall well goodwin has the fancy
footwear
tonight and he had a big swing at that
one the angels
are up four to one going out first and
third mariners down by three
see you're facing a righty swinging his
line up the middle into right center
field for a base hit crawford coming
down the line to score
kyle lewis is into second base
and makes the turn onto third he stands
up there
pal seeger has driven in both mariners
runs
it's now 4-2 angels tim lopes to go
ahead and run at the plate
oh that's a rocket into the gap
lewis scores sieger to third and here
come the mariners tim
lopes with an rbi double for three
angels
well the mariners have grabbed two runs
here in the sixth inning looking for
more
well struck deep right center field
trout watching it lead the ballpark
a three-run homer for dylan moore the
mariners have a 6-4
lead it was upton one out nobody on
looking for career home run number 300.
justin hits one out toward left center
field hit well kyle lewis
going back at the wall gone career home
run number
300 for justin upton and the angels
trail it
by one congratulations to justin upton
home run number 300 got that cutter
and didn't miss it wall standing at
second castro
at first that's ripped out to the alley
right center field that will at least
tie it walls will score
casters on his way to third brian
butterfield waving him home
the relay to the play from d gordon not
in time
to rbi double by brian goodwood halos
have retaken the lead
goodie done good again
chopper slow roller rendon one play
he gets him run scores tie ball game at
7-7
7-7 slugfest fly ball
center field for trout
and here comes jp crawford there's take
the lead again 8-7
looking at on to their 8-7 lead here in
the top of the eighth inning that'll
bring up jp crawford
solid smash up the middle one and eight
beat by jp
two runs are going to score and
americans have a 10-7 lead
oh look at the snare job by evan white
one out
terrific play
well we made the highlights yesterday
i'm assuming that we'll put them in the
highlights again tonight
this should and will do it here comes
kyle lewis
and the mariners winning the ball game
they win it by the final of 10-7 it's
their second win of the season they go
to 2-4